I was about six my favorite toy was mine
slot car track and what that really is
is little electric cars on an electric
road that's electric road the thing
stuck with me
[Music]
I am an engineer rather than to make a
better mousetrap I chose to make the
world a better place we're out our
garden one day and Julie turned to me
and said can you make roads out of solar
panels you know that you know if I can
figure out a way to protect the solar
cells it just might work
it's got I've had the same traction as
asphalt has to be strong enough to
support a fully loaded semi truck
shatterproof fireproof the roads are
collecting heat anyways this thing
collects the power and stores it we
covered all our parking lots and roads
with just 15 percent efficient solar
cells we've produced more than three
times the energy of this country uses
[Music]
solar roadways contain solar cells LEDs
to make your line markings heating
element we're in snow and ice and it's
also a safety feature for the roads when
I first started talking about it half
the people we talked to thought we were
crazy and happened but we're a genius
people wrote articles saying that it was
really audacious and that we were never
gonna accomplish that so we got really
in dire straits financially before we
got our first contract of the federal
highway administration we're making
improvements and eventually we hope this
will become the standard of the future
the planet will be healthier our waters
will be cleaner it's really cool to come
around full circle to what I was
dreaming as a child
if by six or seven-year-old self was
here seeing what we're doing today and
surely be amazed
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]